from nbc news it says raising the
federal minimum wage to 15
an hour proposed a proposal supported by
president joe biden
would result in the loss of 1.4 million
jobs
but would bring nearly 1 million people
out of poverty over the next four years
the study conducted by the non-partisan
congressional budget office
was also found that increasing the
minimum wage would raise the cumulative
budget deficit from 2021 to 2023 by 54
billion dollars
and would drive inflation resulting in
higher prices for goods and services
the cbo evaluated proposal that would
gradually increase the minimum wage
reaching
uh 15 an hour by 2025. okay so
15 in our minimum wage the stuff about
the deficit
increasing by 54 billion dollars that's
the kind of thing that should disturb us
we
we should care um
that's an that's an argument that should
be effective
it's pointing out the increase in
deficit but what we've discovered is
that really nobody
cares about the deficit nobody cares
about spending
um it's we sort of this is just the
truth
both sides of the aisle we take turns
pretending to care when the other
when the other side's person is in
office i mean how many conservatives
over the last four years of trump
said a damn thing about it's too much
spending deficit
all that was out the window was very
little was was said about that
um and that's just the way it goes and
of course but on the left they
they're people that sort of became all
the sudden budget hawks under trump and
now it goes the other way so this is the
way it goes
um that is not going to be it should
probably be an effective
line of argument against any plan is by
saying how it'll increase the deficit
but
um it's not now the part about
losing a million jobs there you go i
mean that that's something people do
care about
should care about and do and in fact
um speaking of related news i think this
is from
biz journals it says kroger is about to
test its first store that offers only
self-service checkout lanes
using enhanced capabilities downtown
cincinnati-based kroger the nation's
largest operator of traditional
supermarkets plans to launch the pilot
test of the all
self checkout store in dallas on
february
17th it's converting one of its smaller
stores um
on cedar springs road for the for the
pilot now this is not
they're not directly making a connection
here but i think we can see the
connection
if you if you try to force these
companies to pay people 15
an hour to do labor that just isn't
worth that
especially when it's labor that can be
replaced
with machines then that's what's going
to happen i don't like it
personally i would much rather have the
people there having you know in
even as an anti-social person myself i
will use the self-checkout lane just on
antisocial grounds
so i guess i'm part of the problem as
far as that goes if you give me that
option then i'll take it
but i recognize that in in reality it
probably would be best if i didn't have
that option
it'd probably be best if there are
actual people doing those jobs
so that is better um
but you force these companies to pay 15
an hour and this is what's going to
happen
as i've said many times the the minimum
wage
should be zero you know that that's
where you start that that's
that's the minimum or maybe a penny like
that's that's the actual minimum of what
of what labor could possibly be worth
and you go up from there and one thing
that gets lost in this discussion
is um is
not only wiping out jobs but if you're
forcing
the employer to pay everyone 15 an hour
effectively giving a raise maybe to some
people who have not
actually earned that and aren't aren't
doing a job that's worth 15
an hour then there'll be a lot of other
employees at that store
who could be worth 20 or 25 an hour very
worthy of of promotion and raises and
now won't get it
because the government is forcing the
employer to give a raise even the people
who haven't earned it
that to me is also a problem i mean
we've we've all had this experience
right when you go to a fast food place
you go
you're interacting with customer service
we've we've all
gone into a grocery store to a fast food
place and we've interacted with customer
service representative
who basically just when you look at them
it's like they're trying to visibly
murder you it's you you can you can see
visible hatred in their eyes
it's not even just bad customer service
it's it's it's hateful because
they hate you for being there so we've
all experienced that
but then we've also experienced customer
service people someone working in a
register or working at a test
who's just wonderful delightful they put
a smile on your face
they're absolutely on top of it the idea
that they should be paid exactly the
same
or that person who hates you just for
being there is automatically worth 15
bucks an hour
all they do is show up make put in
absolutely zero effort whatsoever and
they're automatically worth 15
an hour no i would rather
free up these companies to pay someone
like that like five bucks an hour
i mean you're putting in zero effort
zero
the only effort is just to walk in the
door so pay them five and then
that really awesome customer service
representative who's really on top of it
and makes you feel good and you know
they're just really really good pay them
30 bucks an hour
that to me seems the most just the most
fair hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i
demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat
appreciated